>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C..
>> So next up to the stage we
have a very special author.
Ms. Cokie Roberts is
not the daughter of one
but two U.S. representatives,
and she spent a lot of time
as a young person right here
in and around Washington,
D.C. She grew up to become a
reporter, a TV producer, and a host.
A news commentator.
An analyst.
And she's the author of books
for both adults and children's.
She's won many distinguished awards
for her contributions to journalism,
and she has been named a living
legend by the Library of Congress
who is putting on this
very book festival.
So you can meet Ms. Roberts and have
a book signed from 2:00 to 3:00 p.m.
in the book signing area
across the hall here.
Please give a warm round of applause
to living legend Cokie Roberts.
[ Applause ]
>> Cokie Roberts: Hi guys.
I'm sorry to be up
here away from you.
I wanted to be down there
with you, but they tell me
that the microphone won't work.
And I don't think I can shout
loud enough so here I am.
But I wanted to talk to you about
why I started writing these books.
Which are wonderfully illustrated
by the fabulous Diane Goode,
who's an incredible illustrator.
And maybe the kids, you can
answer these questions for me.
So when you're looking at
the pictures in history
and you see pictures like the
Declaration of Independence
or the Constitution
or things like that,
is anything missing
in those pictures?
Yeah, go ahead.
Women. Women.
There are no women.
Do you think actually -- do you
think there were women then?
[laughter] Really?
How do you know?
I mean, there's absolutely
no evidence of it.
So what do you know?
Who knows?
How do you know there
were women then?
Go ahead. Women to have children.
So you think there wouldn't
have -- there you are.
[laughter] So there probably
wouldn't have been men
without women.
Right? Yeah.
Well, I was really upset that
we never had any reason to know
that there were women
in all of our history.
They were left out of the stories.
And, of course, they
were terribly important.
And so I've written a
bunch of books about them.
And the first one of this period
where we started the country I wrote
about people like Martha Washington.
It's a book called
"Founding Mothers."
Who was Martha Washington?
Somebody else.
Yeah. Go ahead.
She was George Washington's wife.
Right. Well, she was.
But she was also very important.
Every year of the very long
revolution she went to camp
with all of the soldiers.
And George loved for her to be there
because she would cook for them
and sew for them and pray with
them and put on dances and things.
And so she was very
important to the cause.
And there were lots of
other women in that period
who were incredibly meaningful
to the formation of the country.
Can anybody tell me what
Benjamin Franklin did?
Anybody know?
Let's see.
Go ahead. No?
Go ahead. He what?
He did invent stuff.
Did he do anything else?
Yeah. Yeah, you.
He what?
[ Pause ]
The answer was that he supposedly,
according to the young woman,
discovered, as she
put it, electricity.
[laughter] He did have
the kite experiment
and found about electricity.
But one of the other
things that he did was --
we always learn in our history books
that he was the first
postmaster general
of the United States before
there was a United States.
But the fact is he wasn't here.
He wasn't in this country.
He was in England.
And he was there for
years and years and years.
So his wife ran the post office.
And she was very good about it.
And she also ran all the businesses.
And she didn't mind it.
She was very good at it.
But she wanted him to
come home from England.
She missed him.
And she would write to him
and say, come home, come home.
And he would say, no, no, no.
I'm busy here in England.
And then she died.
And so he had to come home.
And he wrote and said my wife in
whose hands I've left the care
of my affairs has died
so I had to go home.
Poor Ben. So I wrote
about those women
in a book called "Founding Mothers."
But there was still
so many more women
who were doing important things
as our country became a young
country and started to grow.
And so I wanted to talk
about them as well.
And some of them were wives or
daughters or sisters of presidents.
Like Martha Jefferson Randolph
who was the daughter
of Thomas Jefferson.
Thomas Jefferson's wife had
died before he was president.
And she helped him a lot.
He wrote her long letters.
And she also had to run his
house for him at Monticello.
Have any of you been to Monticello?
Yeah? And he would have
so many people coming
through that it was
very difficult for her
because she would never know how
many people were going to be there.
And at one point, she had something,
like, 53 people spending the night
that she had to make dinner for.
And find beds for.
And all that.
But when he was the White
House when he was president,
Martha had the first baby
ever born in the White House.
And it was a place
that was not expecting
to have mothers having babies.
And the woman who was
brought in to help take care
of her said she couldn't
find anything.
She couldn't even find
cloths to help.
She said it was bachelor hall.
But Martha had the
baby there anyway.
And here's another person who
had a baby and then carried
that baby across the country.
Do we know who she is?
No, not Pocahontas.
Anybody know?
Yeah. Sacajawea.
And Sacajawea was really
a remarkable person.
After Thomas Jefferson
became president,
he managed to buy a huge part
of the country from the French
and really doubled the
size of the country.
But he had no idea
what he had bought.
And so he asked a couple of
guys named Lewis and Clark
to have an expedition and go
see what it was out there.
And so they went to St.
Louis which was kind
of as far west as anybody went.
And they went up the river
and they found an Indian tribe
that had a Frenchman who had
married a young Indian woman.
She was probably about 15 years old.
And he could translate for them
and she could translate some more
from French to Native
American languages.
And before she left, though, on this
big trip that was going to go all
across the country, she
was about to have a baby.
And so she had the baby.
And as soon as she had the baby, off
they went with crossing the country.
And she had the baby on her
back as she crossed the country.
And it turned out that
she was incredibly useful
to Lewis and Clark.
She would find all kinds
of things for them to eat.
She could find the way when
nobody else knew where to go.
At one point, their boats
got swamped in the river
and she was able to
find the provisions
and get them back in the boat.
And they said she was wonderful and
her husband was completely useless.
He was no good at all.
And then they reach the
Indian reservation --
well, it wasn't a reservation then.
The Indian lands which were
her people and she discovered
that her brother had
become the chief.
And so she was able to
work it out with him
that he would give them horses.
Because they couldn't get
across the Rocky Mountains,
those great big mountains,
without some horses.
So, they traded horses
for some guns.
And she was able to
make that happen.
And she got all the way
across the country with them.
And then all the way back
with this baby getting bigger.
And when they got back,
William Clark said
that she said done incredible work
and that she deserved a greater
reward than she had been given.
Well, that's true.
Because she had been given zero.
Nothing. But he then
did help raise her baby.
So he did try to help her out.
So she was a very important
person in this period of time
when the country was
becoming a new country.
Another person that I had
not known about who turned
out to be a very influential
person in her part
of the country was Lucy Terry Prince
who composed the first
African-American poem.
She didn't write it down.
It was recited.
People said it out loud for
years and years and years.
Like a hundred years before
anybody wrote it down.
But everybody remembered her because
she was somebody who could really,
to not just tell a story
but make an argument.
And she went to court.
Yes, she was.
She was a former slave.
She was in New England but she was
somebody that everybody respected
and she was able to make the
case for her sons to go to school
and to really be known in
the community so much so that
when she died the newspapers
wrote about her.
Which was highly, highly unusual.
For the newspapers to
write about a woman at all.
Much less a woman of color.
But when she died, the newspaper
said, in this remarkable woman,
there was an assemblage of qualities
rarely to be found among her sex.
So they were willing to say she was
really important and did good things
but they were not quite
willing to say
that that was true of other women.
But they were wrong.
Because there were women
doing all kinds of things.
There were women like
Isabella Graham.
Isabella Graham had come the
this country from Scotland.
She had a bunch of little children.
Her husband died.
And she was very poor.
But she started a school in New
York, and all have the girls
of the important people
went to her school.
Martha Washington's granddaughter
Nelly Custis went to her school.
And she made some money at
her school and then was able
to do the work she really wanted to
do which was to help other people.
And so she worked with
Eliza Hamilton.
Does anybody know who
Eliza Hamilton was?
Yeah? She was Alexander
Hamilton's wife.
You all can probably
sing the songs about her.
But they worked to set up an
orphanage which was really something
because women -- married
women were not allowed
to own any property at all.
Their clothes on their bodies,
the jewelry in their ears,
everything belonged
to their husbands.
So they couldn't buy the
land to have an orphanage.
They made sure that it
was an unmarried woman
who represented them to do that.
But then they had to go
out and raise the money.
And take care of getting the
legal rights to the orphanage
which meant going to
the state law makers --
the people who were making
the laws -- the legislature --
and getting them to do what
they needed to be done.
And this was all very public work
which nobody really
expected women to be doing.
But they did it because
they understood
that even though the country
was a great country --
and still is a great country --
and it was growing and exciting
and people were moving west and
able to do all kinds of new things,
that there were some people who
really weren't able to do that.
And who were poor.
And who needed help.
And that was particularly
true of women and children.
And so they started all
kinds of organizations
to help those women and children.
And that's why I always say
that they're the people
who shaped our nation.
Because they're the people
who really made it a better
place for everyone to live.
And there were a loft of women
who were in that same situation.
This is a woman who we know well
in Maryland Elizabeth Bayley Seton
who was a young, rich
woman in New York.
And then her husband lost
his money and then died.
And she found herself in a
terrible situation S.he was in Italy
at the time because he had
gone there to try to get well.
And she became a Catholic.
And that was something
that was not very popular
in the United States at that time.
And so she had a hard time getting
people to come to her school
that she had tried to start
so she could feed her family.
But then she was invited to Maryland
where Catholics were better liked.
And she became a religious woman.
And she started schools in Maryland.
And really started the whole
enterprise of having schools
for Catholic children
called "parochial schools."
She started that whole movement.
But she also started orphanages and
hospitals all around the country.
Again, going west.
Going out by herself.
Or with just another
woman to make it
so that the country would
be a better place for all
of its people whether
they were rich or poor.
And Rebecca Gratz was a
person who did the same thing.
She did it primarily for Jewish
children and in Philadelphia.
And she worked, again, to
just make it a better place
for people who needed some help.
And so these women really did
make this country a different kind
of place from other countries.
Europe did not have
these same traditions
that these women established
in America of saying,
we want this to be a country
that's good for everybody.
Now, some of them had been to Europe
like Elizabeth Kortwright Monroe.
She was married to
one of our presidents.
Anybody know who that
might have been?
Huh? If her last name was Monroe?
Yeah. Hand up back there.
James Monroe.
Right. But before he was
president, he was in France --
representing the United
States in France
and France was having
a lot of troubles.
And Lafayette, who had helped us
a whole lot during the revolution,
had ended up in jail.
And his wife ended up in jail.
And she was afraid she was going
to have her head chopped off
because that happened to a lot of
people in France at that point.
And Elizabeth Monroe went
to the prison and said,
we Americans don't want that
to happen to Mrs. Lafayette.
And so she saved her life.
And it was very, very brave
because they might have
chopped off her head too.
But they didn't.
She was able to come home and be
a first lady of the president.
And then you have Louisa
Catherine Adams.
And she was the wife of who?
Who do you think she
was the wife of?
Go ahead. Which John Adams?
You know? She was the
wife of John Quincy Adams.
Does anybody know the name
of the wife of John Adams?
Yeah. Abigail.
That's right.
And Abigail Adams as
a wonderful character.
And I write a lot about
her in the other book.
But this is here daughter-in-law
Louisa Catherine Adams.
And her husband John Quincy
was not a very easy person
to get to like at all.
And he could be very
much a sour puss.
So she felt that it was really her
job to get him elected president.
And she would write letters back
to her father-in-law John Adams
and tell him about how she was
the one who had to do it --
to get her husband
elected president.
And in the end, she did.
But before he was president,
he was the American's
representative in Russia.
And Russia was -- as it is
still, of course, very far away.
But then, of course,
you had to go by boat.
And then by carriage across Europe.
It was very difficult.
And they went with their
2-year-old son Charles Francis Adams
who then later became
famous himself.
And they discovered
that even little kids
like two-year-olds were expected
to go to fancy parties in Russia.
And they gave them
champagne to drink.
And so she was amazed at that.
And one of the parties he
had to dress in costume.
So he dressed up like
an American-Indian.
And that's the picture
of him in Europe.
But she was a very interesting
person who really would have lots
of parties in Washington so
that she could get people
to know her husband better so
that when he ran for president
that they would vote for him.
And that's eventually what
happened because he was elected
by the members of Congress.
And they had gotten to know
him at Louisa's parties.
So he became the president.
So these were women who
did an awful lot of things.
They were political women.
They were women who
started organizations
that still exist today.
That orphanage that Isabella
Graham and Eliza Hamilton started
in New York is still there.
It's the Graham Windham society
still serving the children
of New York.
And that's true here
in Washington too.
After the British came in 1814 and
burned the city, Dolley Madison,
who was first lady at the time,
worked with women in Washington
to start an orphanage
here and it still exists.
It's Hillcrest still serving
the children of Washington.
So these women were extraordinary.
They not only did all the things
they were expected to do in terms
of running a household and raising a
family and taking care of everyone,
but they really made this
country a more compassionate
and more considerate
place for all Americans.
And their institutions are not
only were remarkable at the time
but they were long-lasting,
still serving people
in this country today.
So that's why I love
writing about them.
Because they are not only important
and interesting but
they're inspiring.
They tell us stories that we can
try to copy and try to be like them.
So I'm thankful that you let me
talk about them with you today.
And if any of you have questions,
I'd be happy to answer
your questions.
So thank you very, very, very much.
[ Applause ]
Yes. You have had your hand up.
You're going to have to scream.
[ Pause ]
No. Lafayette's head
did not get chopped off.
Lafayette they sent to a
prison in Austria far away.
But then he got out
and he came to America.
And there was a huge
celebration for him.
In 1824, they lit up the capital
building with all kinds of lights --
and this is, of course,
before electricity so they had
to do all kinds of fancy things.
And he went around the country and
everybody was thrilled to see him.
And so he lived happily ever after.
Go ahead. [pause] He got out of
prison because the bad people
in France were no longer in control.
Different people had taken over.
>> Why did Lafayette go to prison?
[laughter]
>> Cokie Roberts: Well, he went to
prison because people who disagreed
with him had taken over
the government in France.
Other questions?
Yeah. What time period do I think
I'm going to write about next?
That's a very good question.
After this book, I wrote a
book about the Civil War.
Actually, Washington
in the Civil War.
Women in Washington and the Civil
War and it's called "Capital Dames."
I haven't done a children's
version of it but I hope I will.
Because they were also very, very
important and interesting women.
And for us here in
Washington, it's a lot of fun
because it's about our home town.
But I'm writing a book now about the
period where women finally, finally,
finally, finally got the vote.
And we're about to have --
[applause] we will have in
2020 the hundredth anniversary
of women getting the vote.
So we're going to have a
lot of books about that
and celebrations about that.
And mine is taking a different tact
but it is going to
be about that period.
Anybody else?
Other questions?
Yeah. Go ahead.
[ Pause ]
Question is: What woman in
the book was my favorite?
You know, I don't have a favorite
because they're very
different from each other.
And some of them I would've
loved to have dinner with.
Like Dolley Madison would really
be fun to have dinner with.
And she put on a lot
of good parties.
But then there are people who
I admire like Isabella Graham.
Or a woman I didn't talk about today
but who's in this book who's called
"Judith Sargent Murray" who
wrote very important articles
and books very early in
the late 1700s, early 1800.
And she said then --
she wrote about how men
and women should be equal even then.
And she said, you know, anybody
who sees a 2-year-old boy
and a 2-year-old girl doesn't say
that boys are smarter than girls.
So what happens?
What happens is that the girls
don't get the education they need.
And so she was very keen
that girls got educated.
And really after the revolution we
started seeing many more schools
for girls.
Anybody else?
Yes. You have to come so
that I could hear you.
What was my favorite
book when I was a kid?
Well, I loved books constantly.
I'm going to say one that you
have probably heard too much
about which is "Little Women"
but I did love "Little Women."
And, in fact, in the -- in
"Capital Dames," the Civil War book,
Louisa May Alcott who
wrote "Little Women" is
in that book 'cause she came
to Washington briefly to serve
as a nurse during the war.
But I loved "Black Beauty."
I loved -- there were a series of
books that I haven't seen lately.
They were called the
"Five Little Peppers."
They were the five little Peppers.
And five little Peppers and how
they grew and all that so --
but they I read constantly.
I would climb a tree with a
book so nobody could find me.
Yes.
>> Why did you want
to write the book?
>> Cokie Roberts: I wanted to
write the book because I looked
at pictures from our history
and I didn't see anybody
who looked like me.
And anybody who looked like you.
And so I wanted to make it
so that when you read books
about history you would see
somebody who looked like you.
Well, thank you all
so very, very much.
It's been a real treat
to be with you.
[applause] I appreciate it.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.